when i felt like i could trust police it
was very very different
now i feel like i have no options at all
i literally am like i gotta leave this
area because
what am i supposed to do if someone
comes to my house
and i defend myself i'm gonna end up
like this this omaha guy
what am i going to jump off my balcony
20 feet ah like landing on the ground
run and then there's nowhere to go
there's no way to retreat and i know if
i do anything they're going to claim
peaceful protesters some other
ridiculous nonsense yes my ten-year-old
daughter wouldn't she she never went
back into my life
she never went back into my house after
that night she went and stayed at her
dad's house and then i had to send her
up to visit my mom in another state
because my daughter would not step foot
in the house again she was like i don't
know if they're coming back they didn't
catch them i'm not going there
so i had to move in 12 days the fastest
move of all time in the middle of
nowhere
but and then i did this moved out to the
middle of nowhere too you're going to
love it
i know it's fantastic i love it so we've
been here for the past several days
and everything we got built today like
this room was barren
empty and like trust us getting this we
got like a mixer board over here and all
the stuff it's ridiculous
i swear it's magic there's like a weird
scenario where like cables just don't
work and then you know
but we're i'm trying really really hard
to just get out because november is
coming
and i am not going to be in a city on
november 3rd
through forever yeah after it's like the
deadline to get out of the cities i'm
like
we can i'm look we're what eight days
away now from the from the debates
awesome how could the debates happen is
it that soon
i've been so distracted with covering
like antifa and blm
and all this stuff i didn't even realize
it was coming up so soon
29th wow so we're about we're just over
a week out can that can a debate really
happen
oh yeah joe joe biden he just said 200
million people i know
you might fall asleep oh i'm sorry maybe
maybe they're gonna give them like a
ridiculous dose of uppers
they're gonna have him sleep up until
one hour before
wake him up get him all ready and then
give him some uppers i i'm not trying to
be mean i mean that literally like they
might give him some trunks he wanted to
do a drug test he and biden because he
thinks he's on something
people have said trump's on stuff but
trump's a spry
old man he's spry yeah joe biden's not
so i started thinking i'm like man isn't
everything just
going completely nuts like this can't be
real is is
are we are we in the truman show or
something i think are you guys punking
me
you you are so in it like you say this
sometimes and you might be too i don't
know but
you're seeing the worst a lot so it's
not that
it's not as crazy as it seems no no no
i'm not talking about the worst i'm
talking about the
weird it's definitely weird the internet
thing so
so so hold on let me ask you a question
did you see the colby covington fight
oh no but i watched his interview after
what was
the guy he was fighting was like a pro
black lives matter guy yeah
come on man a guy named covington
fighting a black lives matter activist
a trump supporter in the ring against
him somebody set that up
now the dude is impressive like and his
speech was was awesome
yeah it's cool i liked when they got
into a fight afterwards like a verbal
fight after
that was great did you watch that oh
what happened
well he got a lot of backlash colby did
because he was like
i just got off the phone with the
president has your tribe sent you smoke
signals or something it was
real bad but i like i mean i had
my eyes were watering watching it i was
like i can't believe he just said that
the ufc is the last place that like
comedy and actual put downs and like
yeah
yeah trash talk i saw i saw a meme
and it said something it was like
something like a colby covington and the
covington kid
and it was like two pictures like a
picture of the covington nick sandman
and they're like magette i'm like what
like how
that's it's just a coincidence right but
then the dude literally fought a black
lives matter activist and won
is that like are they are the are the
elders controlling the simulator or
whatever
are they warning us what's gonna happen
in november like trump will win
it's good trump's going to beat them it
just there's a lot of weird little
things like this where it's like that
can't be
real can it like how does this really
happen if it's a magnetic universe
there are no there are no coincidences
we're in a simulation bro
i was uh talking to some other people
who are who are
you know some big personality friends of
mine and i was just like bro are we in a
simulation and
these are like regular normal boring
podcast people and they're like dude
we're in a simulation
i'm half kidding i'm half kidding
because i'm like
it's just everything is happening is so
weird you know
i can't imagine a debate between listen
when i watch these videos of joe biden
i don't just follow like you know
right-wing pundits who are making fun of
joe biden
and i push back when people try and say
joe biden gaffe when he didn't
so there's that one thing where joe
biden said i'm gonna beat joe biden
he didn't he said i'm gonna be joe biden
but he's got dentures
right he was like people ask about my
record i tell you i'm joe biden i'm
going to be joe biden
but people heard a beat and i'm like so
i'll push back on that right
there's also when he said you know you
don't remember when binding said go you
know the thing
we're all created equally under go you
know the thing we say
it's it's not because he didn't remember
the word it's because he panicked
thinking if he said the word god he'd
offend the far left
yeah who don't who really hate that so
he stopped himself undergo
you know the thing he stopped himself
from saying god
so that wasn't a gaffe but i watch
videos of joe biden that dude is not
there
at all no and so how could donald trump
donald trump's going to walk up on stage
and go thank you
uh joe biden thank you your campaign
staff bailed out the rioters
and then it's over done that's it what's
no i
i they did and he'll trump will keep
people like you said 200 million people
will die
but then he won't let it go trump will
keep going yeah that's the nice thing
he's got stamina
he's gonna laugh he's spry yeah he's a
spry old man
so he's persistent we'll talk about that
but i do want to talk about assange and
all that stuff too uh but first
and to kind of wrap up all the talk
we're talking about these riots and
everything do you how do you feel about
trump's job so far dealing with the
riots
not great um i honestly
i if somebody told me that i would be
saying this six months ago i would have
been like you are
out of your mind but i think he should
have
um used the insurrection act like three
months ago
i i thought that at first i was well i
shouldn't say that i was i was thinking
maybe
but then i read a really good article
that basically said what do you think
would happen
when the local police are instructed to
resist when the local government resists
and you all of a sudden have a federal
occupying force in a city that's
rejecting them
yeah it's just a recipe for legit civil
war
but at the same time these cities are
rejecting
u.s law and u.s norms and are
everything it's they're they've gone
nearly anarchist so at what point do you
say these states are you know
so so they're not functioning you saw
what happened today with the doj
announcing anarchist jurisdictions yeah
they're going to try and defund portland
seattle and new york city or take
federal funding away from them
my concern is like that's going to
result in more problems
for the cities i i think it's going to
make them get worse because now they
have no money they're like whatever
it's going to fall apart but the problem
is even that action which i understand
why they're doing it they give this big
outline of all of these cities how they
rejected federal assistance how they
won't enforce the law how they're
cutting loose
cutting criminals loose and i'm like
almost anything trump does
will lead to potential civil war
like the states rejecting federal
authority which they've been doing
like when it came to portland trump sent
some police there to protect a federal
building and they
resisted in every possible way yeah and
everything's got worse
i will say the one thing i've praised
trump on over and over again probably
for the 50 billionth time for those of
you that are familiar with my content
is that the feds deputize the oregon
state police
so any arrest they make now gets
prosecuted by the feds instead and that
wrapped up a ton of these people
yeah but then so here's what happened
the riots came back to portland the
other day
they went to an ice facility and ice you
see these videos of how ice responded
they they just just dropped smoke bombs
the air was a
cloud you couldn't see and if you can
see your hand in front of you and then
they ran up behind
antifa so like auntie was marching
forward with the umbrellas
and they're like firing tear gas at him
and then the whole area fills with smoke
and then all of a sudden the cops run up
behind they went around
ran up behind them and just grabbed them
and arrested them all yeah so then what
happened the next day
antifa stayed away from the feds marched
to the city smashing up local businesses
and where were the police where was ted
wheeler nowhere to be found they
realized
if they go up against trump they get
crushed but so long as they attack the
state level
they're okay see the one of the things
that i'm having a huge problem
like wrapping my head around though is
that
everybody's being like this is what
biden's america this would be biden's
america this would be biden's america
and i'm like this is trump's america and
it's happening right now and it's not
stopping
and these business owners have been
getting screwed for
what 130 days now and nobody's helping
them
and it's not biden's america it's
trump's america and
he has a responsibility to do something
if those local leaders are failing
because it's not those people's fault
it's not the business owner's fault
it's not jake's fault it's not any of
these people's fault that their
government their local government is
failing them
at the very least uh no no
i i do want to say though before people
jump down my throat like i am voting for
trump and i
think that you'd be fool not to vote for
trump i just have some criticisms also
i think i think trump's probably
concerned that if he makes too bold a
move it could affect his chance at
re-election
i think every politician deals with that
yeah i know a lot of people say trump's
not a politician he is now he's fighting
for re-election
so he's a different kind but he might
lose if they
you know they would use everything
against him i don't believe there's
undecided voters
i think that part that people have
picked aside yeah
and his side wants law and order yeah
and he's not
giving us enough law order well i mean
not only that look at the republicans
who are like we're not going to vote on
replacing ruth bader ginsburg it's like
dude literally every republican and
trump supporter to want you to do it
yeah so i don't know whose vote you
think you're going to get
it's it's funny because you have like i
think was like murkowski yeah
and um but did did they flip back and
say they were going to do it or
i don't think so i think she's standing
strong but i could be wrong i was in
assange and antifa mode all day
i haven't kept up on anything else she
she's saying
you know she's not going to vote until
after the she's not going to vote to
confirm or whatever until after the
election
does she does she think there is a a
large group of
trumps like conservatives or republicans
who have decided
they're like they're like every
republican is undecided the point i'm
trying to make is
if 30 of the country is republican 33 is
democrat and 30 are independent
she realized like you realize you'll
lose all of the republicans if you do
this
and so what is she trying to get
democrats to vote for they're not going
to vote for her yeah they want
ridiculous policy that makes no sense
so by by abandoning the core base of
republicans
then what you get some left moderate
democrats who for some reason like the
republican but the democrats it makes
literally
no sense i mean i just think politicians
are narcissists
and they get you know she is an
extremely unremarkable politician
there's nothing special about her
there's nothing interesting about her
she's not a trump or a ted cruz or a
rand paul she's not
uh she's she's boring and
by pandering to the left for a little
while she gets a whole bunch of head
pats from cnn
and she gets her five minutes of air
time where people are like you did a
great thing you're so brave
and it feeds their ego for you know
another year
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you